um yeah we're all good um everything's
kind of um shut in uh we've got a lot of
the animals are inside nice and warm in
their houses their big beds in um and
yeah we're just kind of poised to deal
with whatever we have to deal with
really
finn
sorry have you had any damage what's the
wind been like what storm damage have
you had there's a bit raining
um yeah we've had rain hail
the wind's really starting to pick up
now as well we've had a couple of trees
down so far um so we're just
keeping an eye on it basically we've got
everything we've got the maintenance
team in
they've got their van all set up with
everything that you could possibly need
to fix anything that may
need fixing um so yeah we're just kind
of poised ready to to react really yeah
now we're hearing it's a
once-in-a-generation storm i mean how do
you as a zoo prepare for something like
that
um i think uh obviously we're shut to
the public today um i think obviously
with the the way the storm is and
obviously all the advice is to stay at
home and not travel um i think to to
open would have been kind of promoting
people to travel which is obviously
against kind of what we want people to
do um and then yeah apart from that from
an animal point of view it means that
obviously we can concentrate on the
animals we don't have to worry about um
having public in as well we can just
focus a hundred percent on making sure
that these guys are okay um so yeah just
because of getting all the getting them
in and nice warm beds heating's on
making sure they're getting their usual
feed um and obviously making sure that
where possible we kind of keep as normal
as possible for the animals um because
obviously if we start acting weird and
then they they know something's off um
and that's just going to cause more kind
of distress to them yeah that's
interesting
ready for the damage that's interesting
they must really feel if you get anxious
yeah i mean if uh
they generally they all have a routine
so and if you break the routine um then
they automatically think what's going on
um so yeah they we try and keep as
normal as we physically can um obviously
we've got something shut in that aren't
usually shutting um at the moment um but
yeah just the most important thing is to
keep it as normal as possible for them
and because then that's going to keep
them as calm as possible and then the
kind of the noise of the wind and things
like that will be less
less of a less of a problem to them
basically
what kind of animals do you have because
i can imagine those giraffes certainly
won't be used to this kind of well the
temperatures anyway
yeah i mean the giraffes in general
don't really they're not really a fan of
wind and we've got a massive range of
animals here we've got um from giraffes
rhinos uh we've got a good selection of
big cats um lemurs primates uh quite a
few gibbons and then like meerkats we've
got loads of birds as well so the birds
is one of the ones that we're really
watching and obviously in a in a way the
giraffes um are quite simple in the fact
that we've got them in in their nice
warm house um and their routine is
pretty normal apart from the fact that
the door's shut
so they're quite chilled out as you can
see this is our two boys they're quite
chilled out with us and the birds we're
having to watch a little bit more
closely we've got um two massive avery's
um and obviously the birds flying around
in those avery's uh with the gusts of
winds and the gusts of winds that
they're not used to and they're i mean
they're pretty strong but if we get what
we're forecast um there's going to be
some really strong winds uh we've got to
make sure that they're not caught off
guard um and end up um
injuring themselves basically yeah kim i
just want to ask can you show us how
long a giraffe's tongue is if it doesn't
um hurt them or distress them because i
don't think people understand how long a
giraffe's tongue is come on
he's not going to show you no no oh
there you go there you go
kim it's fantastic i hope everyone stays
safe thanks a lot
yeah noah's thank you very much thanks